you're gonna come for a ride in one of
these it's not every day you get to race
around the track with the head of a
major automaker ready to roll today I'm
doing just that with the president of
Audi of the Americas all right to ensure
that executives like Scott Keogh or
selling cars they can vouch for audi
requires them to get out from the
c-suite and get behind the wheel one of
the interesting things that Audi does
which I don't think any other company
does is Howdy's management howdy board
members go around the world and drive
the cars and they do this throughout the
year the second thing they do is as an
executive you have to get an audi
driver's license so you just don't get
behind the wheel of a prototype unless
you've been certified to drive
and I believe me it's a real rigorous
test out in an airstrip in Germany and
for career salvation you definitely want
to pass that test we are driving the
company's track-ready r8 at the home of
the Audi racecar experience in 2007 we
launched the r8 first real supercar for
the audi brand and really what we wanted
was could we create a home for this car
where people who purchased the car or
people who wanted to purchase the car
could experience what it's really
capable of and we looked around the
country of course one of the first
places you land on is here in Sonoma and
then when we got to this track and we
noticed how technical the track was
absolutely perfect you're 8 and the
driving school are a natural extension
for a brand that has built a name in
racing audi has more lamaze titles than
any other brand except porsche which
like audi is owned by volkswagen a lot
of tracks a lot of cars can go fast I
think what out he likes Lee was
obviously make a quick bar but can you
make a fundamentally sound car how key
is this kind of program to marketing min
previously you just sold the car and
said goodbye now it's important to keep
a closer relationship with the customer
after the point of sale one hundred
percent you can run an ad campaign that
talks about the greatness of the RH so
the greatness is getting it out on a
track and if you look at our owners
overwhelming majority aren't doing this
car to show they're doing because they
love driving they're passionate and
they're enthusiasts I wonder about the
conversion rate how many people come out
and then then end up like buying an RA a
extremely high the bottom line is it all
comes down to selling cars but you might
as well have a good time while you're at
it we get tangled up with sales we could
hang it up with pricing all the business
before it's all the PowerPoint slides
you also forget this is a heck of a fun
business
you